okay your name is Rita Rita where are
you from originally Tucan
Arizona and tell me about your uh your
childhood you grew up with both your
parents no I just grew up with my mama
and she drink a lot have her parties and
I didn't want no be with nobody but my
mama and when her died I had to live in
a hospital when did your mom pass away
when I was 12 years old and I wanted to
die with her but I couldn't they put me
in the
hospital but I tried to get in the
casset with her and they put me to sleep
when I woke up I was in the
hospital they shoot me with some stuff
and now I got to take it all my life
it's
thy so mean you say you tried to get in
the casket yeah with your mom yeah and I
wouldn't let her go but they put me to
sleep and when I woke up I was in the
hospital it's called po Hospital on poie
Street to Sun
so so your mom passes away at 12 and and
you went where I went to PA Hospital in
Tucson Arizona and then I lived at the
county hospital at oh um tucon Medical
Center in a mental hospital oh you went
to a mental hospital yeah I lived in
there like The Exodus and p uh the other
uh I don't know the other
name I was able to take care of myself
until I was
52 I'm 57 I just turned 57 January the
13th and I'm a they say I'm a die at the
county hospital 3 to six week cuz they
found some brain some black stuff in my
brain s can you repeat that I'm sorry
they found some black spots in my brain
at the county hospital on my Ang go stre
and what did they tell you and they say
I'm going to die from 3 to 6 weeks they
couldn't save it but they can help me
into so it sounds like brain cancer
yeah wow you were in a mental hospital
for how how much your life at the
Exodus
until
2014 so you you you've been in the
hospital for most of your life yeah
until
now they let me be on my own but I got
to do get a nurse and stuff check on me
all the time right there by the um
for they a um nurse comes and I got to
go see them and they check on me and
they put a machine on my head and stuff
and where do you where where do you
where do you live right now I just walk
around you're just out in the street
yeah do you have uh any family you have
any kids no only me I'm here you spent
your whole life in the hospital so it's
hard to have a family right yeah I only
know my sister but I don't know know her
I know I got a sister but I only stay
with my mama my mother used to take my
sisters to her her my auntie's house and
keep me
witha and are do you do you mess around
with any of the drugs that are on the
street yes when I was prostituting I did
drugs and then uh I had Sixx and I
caught
germs so you started prostituting when
you came out of the hospital yeah at
5 4 something like that no 50 yeah four
cuz of 52
yeah and now you you just found out you
had brain cancer yeah I found out
2018th that I had Emma
Rizo I can't say
it and what what do you do for money huh
how do you survive I sit on the ground
sometimes and tell them don't they could
give me food or help or donations or I
eat leftovers and then sometimes you
work as a prostitute as well
yeah what's what's your view of life I
mean do you do you do you think life is
just cruel no it's what we make of it
but it's cruel to me because I don't
know nobody I I don't have no family do
you have any friends no cuz I don't have
friends because I feel like um different
sometime they they say I'm or
something I just want to be by myself
have you have you ever had
friends yeah in the hospital my mama's
friends I have my mama's friends
okay Rita thank you so much for sharing
your story it's it's a tragedy it's not
a story it's for real no I know I know
it's
real hi Rita hi how you doing how have
you been fine just great glad to be back
to see you what's going on you never I
never see you down here on skid R
anymore no thanks to you and God no and
won't see me you you've been gone a long
time yes I well taking care of myself
doing things better living better your
whole your whole life was pretty rough
wasn't it yeah up to
56 I met you I'm 60 now when I met you
my life got better but like in your 20s
30s 40s yeah how was your life and I'll
say 40 it was what my life is 40 no but
what what were you doing in your 20s and
30s and 40s oh in my 20 30s and 40s
living in a mental institution is that
right yeah in and out of institution
doing drugs living on the streets yes
and when I met you I started being more
positive of myself you know and I've
been wanting to get away from ski I I
wouldn't take all the credit for that I
I think you did a lot of the work too
and I ain't been um I've been wanting to
get away from sko and asking God talking
to God and he made it possible yeah all
that drugs and prostituting and stuff I
didn't near me like it I just doing it
to P in how did you end up on skid R
from the mental mental institution
getting off the bus and I thought it was
a parade cuz I seen a lot it is a parade
I've seen a lot of tents and I thought
it was a parade so some girl took me and
told me to wait and she wouldn't got me
some drugs and said the souvenir is
coming cuz in Arizona we have tents and
we have parade well and they put up
tents and when I got broke she was like
all they must this for and they ain't
coming now you got hooked into yeah I
thought it was a parade you got hooked
into drugs and yeah prostitution and all
kinds of stuff yes right in this area
yeah so it's not a good area it's not a
good thing
period wow so I mean what's has this
been the like the best time of your life
now it this is the best time of my life
sober clean living happy got my own
place good health and I'm able to share
a moment or two with children or share
with other other people my
experience so they wouldn't fall into
the same trap that they will move on and
have a better life good for you yeah I'm
taking in what was given to me from God
at Mark and sharing it with others to
describe for a better future and a nice
future you're you're very sweet to
credit me for some of that but I don't
know if I was the yes you do deserve it
Mark because I'm uh
experiencing with other people's of what
you taught me help me out with I'm
helping others rather than children so
they wouldn't fall in the same trap
drugs abuse you know so to just to recap
your story your mom you lost your mom
early right I lost my mom when I was 12
speaking of next month I got to go put
flowers on her grade but yes I lost my
mom when I was 12 I had no discipline
and all I knew was people in the mental
hospital did you you finish school or go
to school at all never I don't know
nothing about no school Ed no nothing
about no education my case manager is
trying to Now take me to Adult School
how old are you now 60 years old I
turned 60 January happy birthday never
never too late no it ain't good for you
and uh what what mental disability do
you have they said I got uh uh pa uh
depress extremely depressed posy
extremely of of
nervousness and um bip
podia yeah I cry every Christmas and
stuff I look at my mother's picture put
it in front of me I cry don't want to be
touched don't want to be talked to I go
through it on Christmas Day I'm sure you
went through all kinds of abuse yeah
throughout your life probably only one I
had was my mom and some tough stuff down
here yeah real
tough yeah I would have lost my life if
I wouldn't have made a step forward and
never met you I I don't think I would be
here and where you're staying now is
great right very
CR you said there's a church downstairs
there's a church downstairs and it's not
the race but really it's people who want
to give help you scribe for the better
life
like Mark just like Mark help you live a
better life and peaceful and safe they
really make effort and work with you and
work for you yeah religion plays a big
part in your life does in the area I'm
in yes the area I'm in they really
do they come and wake you up whether you
want to get up or not let's go to church
you know really yeah they really help
you a lot of love that up there where I
live and are you talking with your kids
no I can't find her again I found her
and went to see her a couple times I
can't find her no
more my boys I guess they just go to rot
he they let him out we spend one time
and then I came back to California he
ended up doing another case of murder
this is your son yeah wow so I lost my
family period all I got is
God what do you how do you spend your
days now other than going church SP my
days I been my days arts and craft
making jewelry and serving the lord and
doing um different educations adult
education to get back on the right
track I far as go to adult school and do
arts and crafts Indian jewry and I serve
the Lord go to church it's just nice to
hear somebody's story yeah that ended up
yeah on a very happy note yeah the bad
end the good thanks to God and you Mark
thanks to y yeah and that's for real got
to be a believer though you got to be
strong cuz being the ski road is tough
like we say it's tough your whole your
whole life was yeah if you weak fall
into the CH you still to be here or be
gone dead well I'm just happy I'd be a
part of anything yeah thank you very
much I'm glad to have you in my life too
I really am I really appreciate
apprciate it it's always great seeing
you yeah thank you good to see you too
and know you okay you surviving out of
it let's get you out of this
neighborhood as fast as possible yeah
thank you all right darling like go
byebye
thanks